نايف انت ترى اكثر اكثر مني انا لا استطيع
مشاهده
نعم الان نايف الان نايف كما تشاهد الان
نايف كما تشاهد يتم نعم الان كما تشاهد
نايف
نعم نايف نعم
نعم نايف لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت
عائشه الان تخرج بعد ولاده عسيره وولاده
قيصريه نايف عيشه تخرج من رحم الركام نايف
لا ادري ان كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال لا
ادري ان كنت تسمعني
اكدوا يعني
لا ادري كيف كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال ان
كنتم
الان يعني يحاولون تثبيت
الان يثبتون الان يثبتون الان الان نايف
الان نايف بسرعه بسرعه
الان نايف نايف ان كنت تسمعني ان كنت
تسمعني ان كنت تسمعني
كنت تسمعني ان كنت تسمعني الان نايف على
اكتف نعم على اكتف نعم عائشه على اكتف
المسعفين باتجاه الاسعاف عائشه عائشه يا
نايف عائشه تخرج من رحم الركام عائشه تعود
للحياه عائشه تخرج من فم الموت نايف عائشه
بعد ولاده قيصريه بعد ولاده عسيره عائشه
الان الى الاسعاف الان تصل الاسعاف نايف
وتحمل الان بالاسعاف تحمل بالاسعاف الان
لحظه فرح